[Musique]
bienvenue pitt sur under dogs le podcast
envergure qui comme son nom l'indiqué
vous présentent les profils de joueurs
qui ne font pas la une sur espn mais qui
pourrait avoir une belle carrière en
étant de rafler en fin de second tour
voire non drafté on cherche les frais de
vente vite les daniel gillet marc gasol
nikola djokic patine et tant d'autres
länder dogs c'est un podcast produit par
la date at-il d'envergure nous sommes
sept et à chaque podcast trois d'entre
nous vont vous présenter un prospect de
son choix et de la zone dont il s'occupe
monde europe ou conférence n 6 en guest
on accueille un membre d'envergure potes
qui donnera un avis point de vue sur
chaque prospect
les présentations sont faites c'est
parti salut à tous on va me charger
aujourd'hui présentation de trois de vos
prospects
la désormais fameuse walker de l'inviter
envergure à un retour sur la tragédie
qui a secoué le basket universitaire ces
derniers jours pour ce faire quatre
chroniqueurs vous connaissez très bien
les deux premiers vu qu'ils étaient
présents lors de chaque podcast
underdogs se sont respectivement no
sosies vocaux de yannick noah et jacques
monclar julia et l'udc sont là bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir à tous c'est sa saison
freshman dans la tête a team d'envergure
il a un oeil aiguisé sur les facs du sud
des usa
c'est sa première apparition dans le
podcast bienvenus s'ils bonsoir enfin la
caution envergure le scout préféré de
ton scoot préféré il incarne la
francophonie sur les podcasts basket
c'est l'idole de la tête et team et à
titre personnel je rêve d'avoir un
poster de lui et de son chien en 4 par 3
dans ma chambre
salut ben ça lupiac ans massa va ni
d'être avec vous le plaisir elle partage
et messieurs je vous sens motivé inspiré
un patient sans plus attendre
hunter 2 saison 1 épisode 3 c'est
partout
[Musique]
steve honneur au freshman on va
commencer par toi tu vas nous parler
dans le garde qui évolue chez les
yellowjacket de georgia tech donc croyez
michael devos 2-1 donc seniors à georgia
tech fait un mètre 96 pour 89 kg donc
c'est un athlète plutôt moyen pas très
vertical pas très costaud pas très
explosif non plus il est encore faux
type assez proche pour ceux qui suivent
le basket français de johann tschopp as
le joueur de monaco qui est passé aussi
par le centre fédéral par l'élan
béarnais un peu ce genre de physique son
principal point fort c'est vraiment le
tir à trois points
c'est un fort shooteur il tourne à 40% à
3 points sur sa carrière en six ans sur
un gros volume là cette saison il sur
cette tentative par match et c'est
vraiment là dessus je pense qu'il peut
il puisse faire drafté il a un vrai bras
il est gaucher
pourtant à préciser c'est un joueur qui
est réservé sur le catherine shoot qui
marque beaucoup 6,3 points sur
transition et l'unoci de ses qualités
sur son tir à trois points c'est qu'il a
largement la distance nba capable de
mettre à 8 voire 9 mètres sans problème
c'est vraiment serré à sa qualité
principale
après sur le tir à 3 je n'ai pas vu
tirer en sortie de dribble
j'ai vu faire du pool wapp et c'est
essentiellement sur du c'ur du mi
distance
voilà mais à voir s'il est capable pour
la nba notamment de se créer son propre
tir et a tiré sur du club à trois ça ça
être un enjeu pour lui
sur sûr c'est sur l'aspect physique
comme je disais il est capable comme
d'avoir un premier pas assez intéressant
franchir sur le premier pas mais c'est
pas c'est pas vraiment sûr qualités
physiques il va pouvoir faire son trou
en biais il est plutôt intéressant sur
l'aspect technique c'est un garçon qui
est assez fluide techniquement tu es
assez assez smooth kakadu haendel qui
est capable de changer de direction sur
le drive pour un gaucher draft plutôt
bien à droite il est capable de partir à
droite il a une tendance quand même à
revenir sur la main gauche mais il est
capable de finir sur sa main droite
donc c'est assez aussi assez intéressant
son rôle a pas mal évolué sur sur sa
saison à georgia tech en début de saison
il était plutôt dans un rôle de deuxième
porteur de l'initiateur derrière
alvarado noé alvarado et au cours de la
saison il a pris plus de responsabilités
sur la montée de balle sur la gestion de
la tac
pour devenir finalement notamment sur la
convulsion match au tournoi pour venir
vraiment premiers initiateurs sur la fin
de saison et pas si serrières projet
qu'elle peut aussi construire pour lui
justement pour son avenir
en tout cas on l'a vu vraiment de plus
en plus à celle du poste 2 est vraiment
au deuxième porteur de balle derrière
leurs ragots sur un joueur qui monte
elle a bike ipone avec beaucoup plus de
responsabilités en attaque
voilà donc ça va on va voir aussi s'il
sera capable de un peu plus portés à
baldini ciel jeu sur sûr du niveau
professionnel
voilà voilà dans les dents les défauts
dans les défauts il n'est pas pour
l'instant justement il est un peu pas
mal de ballons il a séduit 8 ballons
perdus en moyenne
ça fait pas mal de ballons perdus il est
donc il manque de qualités athlétiques
comme j'ai dit je vais pas vu évoluer
sur du pick and roll très peu donc je ne
sais pas s'il est capable d'attaquer sur
du pick and roll ce qui est par l hyper
important pour un world / / de la nba
c'est même fondamental et en défense
pareil difficile de juger rend ses
qualités en défense parce que georgia
tech il beaucoup aux oiseaux ont
beaucoup évolué au delà de 1,2 donc
c'est difficile de savoir s'il est
capable de tenir les duels le peu de
fois où il est cependant en indivis qui
s'est retrouvé à devoir gérer les duels
il était correct sans plus il était
capable de tenir son gars il est trés il
est très sérieux sur les défenses de la
défense à l'opposé sur la défense sans
ballon et les efforts là sans être
forcément un joueur défenseur très
important très intéressant ou alors très
bien
ben ton avis sur l'ami michael devos ben
moi j'aime beaucoup michael d'euros je
les ai vus jouer un peu malgré moi parmi
les dab depuis les dernières années
parce qu'ils finissaient toujours par
jouer quelqu'un que j'ai que jusqu'à
ltte et honnêtement il a indiqu toutes
les plus hilarants que j'ai vu dans
l'acier damon hill ce joueur comme
disait si bien sûr bon tir que des
bonnes âmes perdues à evry
mais qui si on lui en demande vraiment
beaucoup ce qui fait je pensions sont je
pense qu'il ait sa carte de visite à une
bille c'est que maîtrise des choses
qu'on veut probablement à lui demander
c'est à dire le tir à trois points et le
pôle up de sortie en sortie d'écran
il est capable de tout faire ce beaucoup
de difficulté à l'intérieur lorsqu'on
lui mais quelqu'un de vraiment très très
gros dans les pattes et beaucoup de
difficultés à venir contre contre les
grands formats
mais encore une fois je suis pour à quel
point on va lui demander
défensivement je le trouve très
intéressant le trou pour deux projets de
deuxième unité je trouve qu'ils se
déplacent bien latéralement
je trouve qu'il ya des bons instants
lorsque je trouve bien le temps d'aider
quelqu'un vient de poker ballon d'un
adversaire moi je trouve que je trouve
que c'est vraiment le oui pourrait
gagner des points soit joueur que je
verrais très bien à être drafté genre
40e comme josh hutcherson ya quelques
années pas qu'il soit comme josh wilson
mais il ya peut-être plus un profil
éventuellement meilleur scénario à la
guerre ni green way moi je vois il fait
beaucoup penser un joueur qui a été
drafté l'année dernière par les hawks
d'atlanta c'est ce qu'à leurs miles de
nsue un peu ce genre de joueur avec un q
est assez développé
de beaux fondamentaux un shoot est ce
que on est un peu dans cette veine là
oui saint geoirs et c'est un joueur qui
est effectivement qu'avec une vraie
maîtrise des fondamentaux
déjà il est assez âgé de 21 ans il a il
était à mon vers des îles à arriver avec
tout de suite quand même du temps de jeu
et la plus développée et c'est un garçon
effectivement qui cochent un peu tout
les cas de ce mouvement un basketteur
sur le postérieur aujourd'hui alors
qu'il est capable de de faire des passes
main droite main gauche aient accès à
terre il et il a un bon greed
il va finir correctement sur les
fissures main droite main gauche
effectivement comme l'a dit ben il est
pas hyper à l'aise au contact et ce qui
est paradoxal sicap a développé deux
flotteurs ce qui est assez surprenant
parce que c'est un garçon qui a l'air
quand même d'avoir plutôt dû toucher là
dessus sur les finitions mais distancé
d'une censure du bloc dès qu'ils se
rapprochent ils allaient forcément finir
proche du cercle et c'est pas
effectivement son son point fort donc ça
pour voir aussi si on va voir s'il va
pouvoir développer un flotteur mai mais
oui c'est un garçon qui est
techniquement et très très propre
vraiment c'est tout ce qu'il fait est
très propre
nick repas là bas il est assez altruiste
il joue plutôt jussie force pas grand
chose et c'est vrai qu'il s'est cassé un
garçon qu'on imagine taux bien
s'inscrire dans un projet collectif sur
une seule une seconde équipe
et voilà et faire il faire le travail
sans problème quoi c'est vrai qu'il est
très propre techniquement hugues un avis
sur ma gueule ouais ouais ça c'est un
joueur que j'aime bien moi j'adorais la
paire avec son meneur du coup des
cartels de gta là du coup elles sont
incroyables et puis il avait il avait
l'avantagé de jouer avec moi ce soir est
requis un mille poesy ne pètent près du
panier c'est un gars vraiment qui finit
très très bien donc ça c'est cool
un vrai shoot comme comme ça a été dit
hao frère je lâche tout près vous quand
tu parles d'escale à metz km il a pe
c'est ce spin move là incroyable qui en
fumée tout la ligue pendant plusieurs
années et des épaules un peu plus large
moi je pense que on va pas demander du
tout tu pouvoir
à défaut d'attaquer le panier quoi et en
vrai vrai shootant vrai vrai bras il
trouvera une place
possiblement au niveau supérieur julien
sur le yellow jet web apparaît moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé je suis bien mieux parce
que je connaissais pas et par rapport à
sa technique là il c'est vrai que c'est
pas un gars qui est très rapide et pas
du tout verticale quoi on peut le dire
mais moi j'aime bien la façon dont qui
change de rythme voire plus - quand il
attaque le panier la transition du bien
de rythme et il est capable comme tu
l'as dit il est très technique pour
attaquer le panier et giuly touché et
par tu vois moi j'ai la question que je
m'étais posé quand tu as déjà à moitié
répondu ce qui est ce qu'il est capable
de ste mans 2-2 s'améliorer parce que
moi j'ai pas vu beaucoup de couleuvres
de steinbach 28 par les docks moi j'en
ai pas vu beaucoup et ils shootent les
pieds les pieds bien au sol
ouais ce que j'ai surtout vu moi qui m'a
intéressé ça dépité en sortie d'écran et
encore une fois comme ceux dits
s'installe vraiment c'est quelqu'un qui
a des bons fondamentaux de thiviers pas
de queue pas de reach un peu étrange et
pas vraiment shooter comme on nous le
montre à l'école
messieurs on a fait le tour sur michael
de vaud
on est bon pour lui on passe au suivant
on va partir avec hugues on prend la
direction du texas avec le scouting
report d'un joueur assez on va dire
étonnant crgm barde
ouais on m a redonné un peu à l'opposé
du mac os vient de faire avant en terme
de propreté
je préviens connaissions très gros
cropper complètement fou indienne à mort
du coup c'est un combo guard pour moi
plus + 2 mai comme bogarde effectivement
leader de tissus ont une équipe de la
victoire tient fait un résultat assez de
moyens cette année mais avec comme des
bons joueurs il y joue aux côtés d'un
bonheur mac miles un tout petit meneur
de poche
et puis un très très gros pivot kévin
samuel à une mobilité très douteuse mais
qui prend de la place et redit n'aime
pas c'est un score comme je dis c'est un
métier capable de finir avec les deux
mains n'importe comment il prend des
shoots ampoules up
beaucoup de clubs jamais en équilibre il
est tout le temps en train de rechercher
la faute à ce balancement tous les sens
c'est un enfer à regarder et pour les
défenses mais ça met dedans on a un mec
qui a un bon haendel alors y perd
beaucoup de ballons parce qu'il tente
n'importe quoi il fait maintenant
beaucoup à ce n'importe comment mais en
un contre un c'est un gars qui qui prend
ses duels et qui va marquer des paniers
on sait quand une bière on aime bien
tenté des coups avec des gars comme ça
hyper l' hyper flashy et l'hyper fait
pour un modèle de summer league monbahus
s'inscrit là dedans
défensivement parlant voilà j'ai fini ce
qui défend pas il remplit pas il
communique pas sur les sweats il fait
pas d'effort il se bat pas dans les
écrans bref qui a environ tout le monde
fou mais bon c'est le dit fort d'une de
cette équipée et voilà six sites à
parier sur un mec pour mettre quarante
points summer league décroché un contrat
et qui finiront chine au bout de deux
semaines c'est lui et quid de son
comportement sur le terrain
là je crois que c'est aussi c'est assez
pour eux on prédire
c'est un fou furieux l'iped des plombs
il peut rentrer dans son adversaire il
parle tout le temps il cherche tout le
temps des fautes il va tout le temps
regardé l'arbitré et parler mais par
contre je peux quand même lui
reconnaître que sur des fins de match un
peu serré bon bah il fait quand même des
bons choix
notre arc il ya des c'est n'importe quoi
sur 38 minutes dans les deux dernières
minutes
il va te trouvais justement le bon geste
faire la bonne faute marqué son and one
et a regagné son équipe sur les peu de
fois où il a pu lire que dès cette année
belle récompense de mj nel barde qui
tourne à 34% à 3 points ben moi j'ai été
surpris à quel point ces pourcentages
étaient aux toilettes et de regarder
jouer et que ce joueur pour qui manger
la difficulté un argument pour qu'il
soit draft et je le trouve je trouve que
je vois physique c'est quelque chose qui
sait quelque chose qui pour lui puisque
la liste les crises et qui peut être
capable de prendre le prochain pas je
pense qu'avec beaucoup d'amour il
pourrait jouer potentiellement poste 2-3
parce que l'homme - juillet le ballon
personnellement le mieux je me sens et
dans un petit dans une multi pistes
alignement est en général post 3 je vous
ai gr sacramento à quelques points comme
ça ça ne met sur le port est dément mais
sinon on parle pas d'un shoot en
extraordinaire on parle d'un gars qui
défend je suis quand il à l'envi
défendre on parle pas d'un passeur
extraordinaire non plus arrêté sur un
sujet un jam aime bien jouer ses ports
je sais pas qu'est ce qui me donne comme
je vous rappelle joie par une chance sur
lui au deuxième tour mais je sais pas de
casque et sa carte de visite comme
joueur à brad et moi ce sujet m je pense
que c'est ouf c'est que d'habitude mon
jour je suis du genre je trouve pas de
second tour vous savez c'est mon truc et
tout mais lui de façon assez
incompréhensible dans tout les mots que
tu regardes il a une sacrée cote ça que
j'en parle là ce soir c'est parce que
c'est jour de jours que je déteste on
regarde et je l'écouté parce que dans ma
conférence et il a mis des gros cartons
mais il a une vraie vraie vraie grosse
cote et on en parlait dans un profil à
la haine et au blick ni de ce genre de
mec l'a complètement fou pyromane qui
produire n'importe comment ou trieurs
que vous avez pu avoir au nic là les
gars qui se place dans ce dans ce moule
la con way il ya effectivement un petit
peu de ça moi j'aimerais revenir sur sa
mécanique de tir qui est pour le coup en
dise est de 2 go qui était à ses pieds
dans le sol quand il ajouté lui c'est un
peu pareil en plus de ça on a façon
c'est pas une mécanique qui est fixé que
ça change selon selon les besoins et
envies devient voyage à mais un prix un
tiers prend on est il pas après comme je
te dis dire charge tout le temps la
faute donc ils se jettent tout le temps
en avant il l'oeil a les bras qui
partent un peu partout les formant un
peu partout c'est vraiment horrible
horrible à regarder mais il plante quand
même alors surtout en club me plante
quand même julia est ce que tu as vu ce
phénomène charmant j'aime bien les
gaulois fluide comme sa notion active
qui vont vite
oui voilà une championne importe quoi et
mais il c'est un gars qui s'amusent en
jouant et je pense que c'est ça aussi
que je sais pas ça peu d'aidé ou le
coton le cramer parce qu'il n'est pas
prouvé je sais pas on peut dire ce à
quoi il ça part dans tous les sens et tu
parlais des pertes de balle et airs de
bal qui fait cesser sur des sujets
complètement anodin c'est fou quand il
est tout seul il fait un coup un spin je
sais pas pourquoi puis balance la balle
sur l'adversaire c'est c'est un gars qui
est vraiment étonnant ouais son jeu si
c'est un petit peu déroutant quoi après
c'est comme un gars qui a progressé
j'ai regardé ses stats il a progressé
pendant ces quatre années à la fac quoi
donc tous les dons maintenant en
apportant du stif sur ce ce comment
comment on peut voir le qualifier c'est
cette boîte botteur surprise voilà ce
feu d'artifice et reviennent hallebardes
j'ai pas j'ai pas vu de match complet
j'ai eu des extraits des images il a il
a quand même parce que je n'ai pas
l'impression qu'ont ils à il a quand
même un morphotype intéressant quand
même mais très délié y coran l'on pense
que c'est ça aussi qui fait que
aujourd'hui il apparaît dans les modes
draft quand même après trois oui la
gestuelle du tir pique les yeux c'est
vraiment le ballon tu pars sur le côté
comme ça
après j'ai pas j'ai pas vu en situation
de match on peut pas en dire tellement
plus quoi très bien messieurs ont fini
avec julien qui va nous présenter à
l'intérieur allemand qui a un nom à
consonance l'uso phone et qui évolué
avec les cardinaux de standford voilà
oscar da silva c'est un intérieur
dominant de la pac twelve depuis deux
ans maintenant
ils étaient cette année dans la course
au début d'année dans la course aux
playoffs venir dont pacte wales
il est dans la force team actuel depuis
deux ans aussi donc leader de l'équipe
de stanford l'année dernière et cette
année encore
bon voilà une taille correcte de m 6 2 m
16 d'envergure je crois quand même dès
2016 athlètes correct plutôt bon ce
coureur pas mauvais au contre mais je
pense que sa force principale c'est son
cerveau son cerveau bien fait alors
c'est un mail for one smart for one je
sais pas comment dire un intérieur qui
réfléchit beaucoup fabien je réfléchis
en tout cas donc il joue à stanford qui
a galéré cette année c'était une année
compliquée on entendait beaucoup au
début de l'année avec l'arrivée de
williams qui était là pour mon dire
compléter un effectif qui était déjà
solide malgré la perte d'une artillerie
qui est un vrai qui partira d'alex à la
draft
maintenant tu étais beaucoup les
premiers matches étaient très
encourageants avec un cinq majeur
plutôt solide même s'il n'y avait pas
vraiment de meneur et puis après ça a
été la cata les deux arrières titulaires
qui se blessent qui joue très peu de
matches dans la saison des jeunes davis
le titulaire à la mène qui est pas
vraiment un honneur mais qui met la
baraque disparaît très vite donc jeunes
années galères et il a tenu
oscar passive a quand même tenu de choc
niveau des stats même si donc lanières
pas été terrible donc da siva c'est donc
de mettre si ça peut mettre 16 d'environ
2 kg sa force principale on attaque je
pense que c'est ce qui peut un peu faire
plein de choses il est c'est chose qui
fait plutôt bien
il est fait de façon régulière à chaque
max donc il joue essentiellement peut
jouer pasto poste nous attaquions poste
qui l'a souvent aussi la balle derrière
la ligne à trois points où il a relancé
du drive main droite ou la gauche aux
dribbles quoi il arrive à dribbler dès
demain sa horde droitier quoi mais il
arrive aussi à devenir main gauche
plutôt bien c'est un rebondeur correct
qui a surtout un gros moteur rebond même
offensif il a un bon deuxième saut et
puis il a des bombes poste bas après au
niveau du shoot c'est plus compliqué les
souvent campé derrière la fin à camper
il est souvent placé derrière la ligne à
trois points au début dé de la taxe mais
il souhaite que deux fois par mois en
moyenne à trois points avec une réussite
finalement assez calme dans la réussite
moi j'ai 31 700 mouais ça donc avec une
mécanique un petit peu discutable mais
alors maire lui c'est franc lancers
francs il la trouve bien il ya 1 400
genre ok mais il a une embauche aux
lancers francs après c'est là plutôt une
belle mécanique ou non c'est frau mais
au niveau des trois points 6 passes
ben est ce que tu as vu cet intérieur
allemand bien sûr que j'ai vu il va
surtout l'année dernière parce que je
venais aussi catastrophique et
infernal moi j'aime oscars de silva je
trouve pas que c'est un joueur qu'une
option aide vraiment très prononcé en
bim ce genre de joueur qui donnera pas
de montage
c'est à dire c'est un joueur qui ont un
ring établi 2 qu'est ce qu'il sait faire
des caisses qui sait pas faire bille de
peinture jamais en dehors des lignes
dire qu'il va il faut protéger le cercle
ils vont rouler au panier en attaque qui
va finir au poste de bord lorsqu'il ya
des rebonds offensifs
à ce propos il veut il faut jamais rien
de spectaculaire mais il donnera jamais
notre tête à son entraîneur encore un
colosse ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
est très très vendeur
mais ce qui fait en sorte que je sais
pas s'il va être drafté mais c'est un
joueur que moi je crois qu'on envoie un
billet plutôt que tu as chauffe ce
quelqu'un qui bouge bien aussi pour son
format qu'on parlait tantôt il des axes
vraiment bien ballon ce qui fait en
sorte que lorsqu'il a fondé joueurs qui
sont beaucoup plus gros et grands et
brooke lui il a tendance à l'oea a joué
avec leur équilibre beaucoup ce que je
sais quelque chose que j'aime chez lui
c'est il ya un profil de mon profil de
relayeur vermand speak pour la nuit et
je sais pas s'il va la faire mais moi je
crois bien qu'ils boivent au moins avoir
une invitation au sommet ligue est passé
au travers du des contrôles de dix jours
et tout le tralala
moi j'ai deux stats à vous soumettre
il a 35 pour cent ans de carrière
à trois points sur 250 tirs et il a un
trou shooting de 64 est ce que il n'ya
pas quelque chose à gratter pour cette
fameuse recherche très zen biais du
stretch file il parle de pas grand chose
un an nahl quand il était en sélection
allemande en u18 discutait pas du tout
il joue ailier mais je n'étais pas du
tout enfin bien jouer y est vous pouvez
jouer à est 10e et souhaitait pas du
tout à trois points je crois que sur la
compet je prends trois shoots à trois
points en 2016 je crois donc il part de
pas grand chose au niveau du shoot donc
il ya quand même trois gression sur les
quatre années qui passent et puissant
comme comme vous demandiez et danser
france encourage sa réussite et sa
mécanique
après ce qu on demande beaucoup aux
intérieurs son retour en nba maintenant
ça va être capable de protéger avoir
cette notion de spe singh verticale il
se situe comment à ce niveau là alors
c'est un fameux contrat rhône est il à
il ya 1,3 je crois cette année 1,3
comparé à max je crois la stat
c'est quelque chose comme ça mais c'est
pas moi je n'ai pas vu en second rideau
c'est pas un contrat vous pouvez donc un
constat dans un contre un justement
parce qu'il a il se place tout le temps
bien pour défendre et suffisent en
galilée une bonne mobilité quand il peut
contre des intérieurs et il arrive à
placer des contres 1 quand ils jouent
contre tsonga quoi en second rideau moi
je n'ai pas trop vu montrer ses pages
voire très très qu'il a trait au dessus
du panier donc de ce côté là bas et
maintenant vous en parler les gars qui
le je trouve qu'il a un peu le même
bagage technique qu'un certain pivot de
stanford qui est devenu un peu le poster
boy des switchs par yvan mbiye avait
lorsqu'il était drafté parce que vous
savez de qui je parle
le buzz aux robinets du directeur marc
lopez qui était un peu joueur de poste
bas qui défendent un bien mais tu
défends que thouars etc te ment il ya un
peu un bagage technique c'est pas le
même profil athlétique et de broc lopez
mais oui je pense que ce qu'on voit aux
lancers francs et chemins à trois points
je crois pas être le potentiel de
développer ce profil là peut-être pas au
même niveau mais je pense que brook
lopez a aussi retrouvé une une équipe
qui avait besoin de ce qu'ils avaient à
offrir vous qui avez manqué lui demandez
pas trop
donc si et chansons lorsqu'un incident
pourrait avoir une trajectoire assez
similaire hugues et steve je vous ai pas
entendu sur oscar posthume cheveux je
vais commencer ouais moi j'aime beaucoup
parce que j'ai une pensée pour le petit
axe est le meilleur pivot la gonfle
voici 100 fun je l'attendais le
l'attendait merci non mais super joueur
qui en vrai le seul qui n'a pas été aidé
comme l'a dit julien par cette équipe 1
200 kg était apathique avait 15 ailleurs
william ce très très très décevant
donc ils ont mis du temps à chercher et
c'est moi ce que j'aime bien chez ce mec
est ce que je pense je peux retrouver en
nba actuellement on profite länder 16c
brenton clark que qu'à développer un tir
dans ses années universitaires
même s'il est moins athlétiques que
bredin que la paix comme sont vraiment
fondamentaux un peu jeune pour ça et
c'est tout ou bien daniel tu as aussi
dans le le côté un peu européens
allemands aussi mais qui peut justement
savoir virer ce corps prendre
l'ascendant sur des mecs un peu plus
gros défensif on être intéressant et
toujours être utile en fait sur le
terrain et je pense que c'est le haut le
rôle de da silva s'il existait au niveau
nba
c'est vrai la csc big men intelligent
qui peut un peu un peu tout faire et qui
est surtout très fort ce compagnie
style oui moi je suis d'accord
tout ce qui a été dit là il a sur le
match j'ai vu moi j'ai vu contre north
carolina en début de saison il a en plus
il avait une attitude sur le parquet
avec ses coéquipiers qui étaient très
positives et leader toujours encouragé
en plus donc ça a l'air d'être un gars
aussi qui facilement intégrés dans un
collectif en tout cas qui est très
positive avec ses coéquipiers c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir des joueurs
comme ça dans une équipe
un good guys ouais il avait là en tout
cas en tout cas des très très très
positif très leader dans street iv
standford je pense que ce timide de cdc
qualité c'est l'adaptation c'est un gars
qui est là il ya arrivée en allemagne à
un mois là il est déjà titulaire dans
une équipe pro le reason c'est une
équipe qui tout en haut du championnat
allemand donc ça veut dire que c'est sa
place et qui joue même s'il a des stats
est énorme et il joue dans une équipe
pro qui a l'habitude de gagner donc ça
montre quand même qu'il sait s'adapter
et puis c'était d'être comme remarque
mais quand tu arrives à standford sais
que tu as quand même un bagage
intellectuel en tout cas de tu vois
cognitif assez intéressant et je pense
que voilà c'est les mecs cérébraux ça
sa force est toujours appréciée par tous
ces trous noirs ou quoi
il est diplômé en biologie l'énergie
c'est une tête pour l'occasion six
langues il parle six langues
six langues il parle sinon bien dans un
récit à levier non mais franchement
aussi à ce niveau là messieurs sans
transition je vous propose de passer à
notre wild-card pédagogique de notre
invité qu'il ne parlait de la notion de
potentiel de pourquoi les joueurs phares
de la march madness sont souvent drafté
au second tour ben sékou toure de façon
religieuse
oui ben quand pierre m'a demandé de
parler du sujet que je voulais je
pensais de discuter de quelque chose qui
me cause des arguments sur twitter à
chaque année c'est lorsqu'un joueur une
grosse perf au à la march madness
on lui dit oh mon dieu il pas être
repêché loto au mont dieu est repêché il
va être repêché oh mon dieu il est
repêché top 3 il ya quelques années par
exemple on avait un carnet de whites qui
jouaient pour produit tu venu mail bah
oui mais qu'il avait continué bien il
avait mis en ondes ce genre il est
complètement fou et là on s'est mis à
dire si le nouveau staff curie bla bla
bla et bien sûr discrétionnaire world a
été drafté je crois 33e au total et ou
de difficultés à jouer et puis il ya eu
la même chose dernièrement avec voyons
qu'elle sait que qui seront donc ajouté
me qui a mis une raclée à utiliser le
prochain événement bac c'est ce même
souci
il fait je crois 75 kg et donc pourquoi
est ce que ces joueurs là sont toujours
de racheter au deuxième tour ou pas de
rajouter du tout eh ben ça revient
souvent à la notion de upside donc de
potentiel pour être la table surface
c'est à dire une équipe nba pour
rechercher certaines choses qui vont
être plus importante chez un prospect
que sa connaissance du basque c'est à
dire et il faut avoir un certain profil
physique pour chaque position ça des
conventions vont demander aux jeunes
qu'ils soient longs qu'ils soient grands
qui soit rapide qui soit explosif
si un jour un profil physique
intéressant pour une équipe un billet
que c'est ce qui va être rachetée et
n'importe quelle équipe pour lui montrer
à jouer au basket
ça peut prendre du pa jeune ami à moi
qui enseigne le basket dans laquelle jr
de dallas qui avait dit
quand giolias surrender est arrivé sur
le circuit a eu quelques années tout le
monde savait qu'il allait jouer dans la
nuit parce qu'il était plus gros plus
grand et plus fort que tout le monde et
oui je pense que jolie blonde n'a pas
vraiment eu à apprendre le basque
jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent à kentucky et
aujourd'hui je veux dire on parle d'un
des meilleurs joueurs c'est carrément un
des meilleurs mois de juillet
présentement il était nommé donc
l'apprentissage s'inscrire c'est souvent
secondaires seront là et si c'est sûr
que pour certains joueurs comme par
exemple challenger alexander ça a été il
y avait chez lui quelque chose de
naturel syndicat veut y jouer ses
joueurs basques de façon instinctive
donc je lui il savait jouer il avait le
profil physique c'est juste que il a été
belle très bien caché par le système de
john calipari ou que dirige l'absence de
système de john calipari mais le plus
gros les grosses exemple que j'ai de
meilleurs exemples que j'ai vu de tout
ça c'est il ya quelques années je n'ai
pas de boulot et je regardais j'ai
regardé tous le combined nba les trois
jours d'une campagne be ce que je ne
souhaite pas à mon pire ennemi c'est
vrai et il y avait un dénommé steven
adams
j'avais vu jouer à pittsburgh qui
étaient là et que pittsburgh n'avait
absolument rien fait d' intéressant
pendant la nuit mais il est arrivé à la
cocoben il s'est mis à mettre des shoots
de 18 pieds et s'est mis à écraser tout
le monde sur les sur les tests physiques
et steven avait été drafté le triple
monde s'est mis à crier oh mon dieu
c'est le prochain qui veut garder
prochaine
c'était pour ça mais les gens ont vu le
potentiel en steeple hommes même s'ils
n'étaient pas s'il n'était pas au
raffinement du tout et il était de
rafler 12e au total si je me rappelle
bien par oklahoma city
donc le potentiel l'idée l'idée que que
nba va avoir un jour ou deux qu'est ce
qui peut leur être plus importante de
caisse qui est alors même donc je vois
des joueurs qui sont très très bien
polis niveau basket sont pas aussi
importantes que les joueurs qui ont le
potentiel de devenir meilleur qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont la première ronde
surtout le premier tour de draft repose
énormément sur le rop side c'est à dire
qu'on va prendre des risques sur des
joueurs qui sont pas développés et en
deuxième ronde deuxième torrent votre
trouver des joueurs qui sont qui savent
jouer au basket qui vont boucher des
trous dans l'équipe
donc du coup est ce qu'on peut faire
aussi le je suppose on peut faire le
chemin inverse dans le sens où les
prospects qui ont déçu mais qui vont ses
atouts justement ce que tu disais les
atouts physiques et/ou athlétique c'est
pas parce qu'ils ont ils ont déçu qu'ils
vont être drafté beaucoup plus beau que
ce qu'ils auraient dû être
en effet en effet c'est ses cages de
dire si le joueur arrive de montres qui
sait faire des choses en entrevue
montrent qu'il est coach a mais qui veut
apprendre les jeunes et les équipes vont
se battre pour lui apprendre à jouer ou
parce qu'elles suscitaient s'il t'arrive
avec si tu rencontres un jour un gars de
ses pieds qui va prendre un jour parce
qu'il ya même toit sur lui montrèrent
jouer au basket c'est c'est une
opportunité pour tous c'est une
opportunité pour tous les équipes
donc c'est vraiment nous pensons que les
workouts et les entrevues sont vraiment
très on veut voir le fit avec la culture
messieurs je vous ai des questions par
rapport à ça non moi je suis totalement
d'accord avec ce qu'il a de trop dit
bravo magnifique pense que je baigne tu
va prêcher un convaincu pour l'ensemble
de l'équipe et c'est pour ça que
peut-être aussi on est dans la tête et
tim d'envergure vous pouvez pas finir ce
podcast sans évoquer malheureusement
terre ans clarke comme vous le savez
sûrement jeunes prospects kentucky qui
venait de se déclarer la draft été
victime d'un accident de voiture mortel
dans la nuit du 22 au 23 avril
c'est le deuxième joueur de 26 ans a
perdu la vie dans ces conditions après
la disparition de ce quart frayères fin
de grand canyon il ya un mois toute
l'équipe des podcasts transatlantique a
une pensée pour sa famille ses proches
et ses coéquipiers messieurs que vous
inspirent ces tragédies ben quote c'est
pour moi je trouve ça comme je m'exprime
sur twitter bouton sommes vraiment
tristes étrange parce que quand on se
calme les joueurs sur clermont vient
peut avoir l'impression de les connaître
et j'aime beaucoup
un terrain du club je trouve être
beaucoup de outside qui avait pas eu la
vie facile à dans un kit qui
complètement chaotique mais qui a montré
plus de création s'est montrée la
défense ces six mois je le voyais
facilement peut-être fait le tri début
en tout 15 14 et voyait peut-être
c'est une tragédie sans nom qu'un jeune
joueur comme ça perdre la vie à cet âge
parce qu'ils ont tellement de
responsabilités sur les épaules hier
tellement de choses qui reposaient dans
la vie de ses proches sur les épaules de
terrain scott et kiki qui décèdent comme
ça et quand lui qu'on le prive de tout
ce qu'il a travaillé si fort pour
mériter
[Musique]
ouais je te rejoins complètement sur le
côté projection c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression de les accompagner quelque
part même si on n'est rien du tout je
fais que que que de regarder les matchs
mais à force d'euros de regarder ses
joueurs de bande de les voir évoluer
progresser aussi parfois avec un petit
un sentiment d'attachement qui n'est un
petit peu et impression de faire partie
d'un entourage peut-être un peu lointain
mais quand même d'un entourage
donc ça moi ça fait vraiment aussi très
très bizarre quand j'ai appris la
nouvelle j'étais bon il y avait aussi la
rumeur dans le lot 2 par rapport à
béziers boston et enfin évidemment des
résultats assez horrible et il les deux
en même temps ça a été une calamité sans
nom aussi et enfin je sais pas comment
vous messieurs où vous l'avez vécu moi
je t'avoue gelé fut dès le réveil
donc c'était ouais un peu compliqué
surtout je l'avais j'avais pas mal
scouts et j'avais ce petit bp porte tech
et des threads sur twitter qui en
préparation donc finalement gelée quand
même sorti en hommage soit parce que je
pense que c'est la meilleure des choses
que je pouvais à ma manière faire pour
lui
je n'avais pas mal suivi ce petit gars
là qui ont observé une grosse blessure
nous qu'avait joué que huit matches et
tout facile tu es vraiment
une année une année est affreuse et
ouais bien sûr tu développes de
l'attachement pour ces gars que tu suis
là je pense que la preuve étant que
quand ils arrivent finalement en nba tu
es un peu jaloux tu sais de devoir les
partager avec lisa kokoro tous les fans
des cavs qui font et c'est mon gars show
mode à waimes et salace mon cas avant
comme m donc ouais j'ai forcément très
très touché et puis je pense je pense à
la famille
et voilà à quoi je on a espéré que ça
que ça arrive en moins possible à tout
l'univers de toute façon et c'est la
pire chose pour un parent de
départements seront dépensés en juillet
at il pas pareil vous avez dit on
ressent tous le mix des motions dont
vous parlez quoi où je n'ai gars qu'on
connaît pas qu'on suit comme ça et qu'on
apprécie d'un coup à la trappe de
manière un peu brutale un contact mme
mota décédé moment un petit peu étrange
c'est sûr messieurs il va être l'heure
pour nous de nous quitter déjà en
espérant que la prochaine fournée pas à
annoncer d'autres mauvaise nouvelle
parce que c'est pas le lieu et j'ai pas
envie ça devienne une habitude surtout
donc eu que julien style et ben merci
beaucoup pour votre participation merci
à vous auditeurs de nous avoir écoutés
n'hésitez pas à commenter poser vos
questions là qui est partagée
massivement je vous rappelle aussi qu'en
l'intérieur c'est un site internet
envergure principaux vous retrouverez
les stats les derniers scouting les
portes des big board
il ya aussi des articles le dernier en
date de manu halal est un must read
si vous voulez tout savoir sur les
pépites du gâteau national 2021 prenez
soin de vous on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour un nouvel épisode de under
dogs salut les gars pas le pion à 6 h
[Musique]